bảo tạo PowerPoint từ một PowerPoint từ chương trình Document Linkage mới,
Docs, chỉ cần những thông tin chính.
Và thế để xem xem AI của mình làm được như thế nào nha.
Đây là bản Powerpoint mà AI mình đã đã tạo cho mình.
Nó khá là đơn giản và cũng chỉ là liệt kê những thư mục
đơn giản nhất về cái workflow của mình và
Chào các bạn, hôm nay mình lại làm series về AI công việc văn
phòng. Tập trước, mình đã dùng skill của anh Ivan để tạo một skill
cơ bản về Excel cho AI của mình.
Hôm nay mình sẽ dùng skill khác của anh Ivan để về PowerPoint.
Kỹ năng này của anh cũng đang được hơn 40.000 người tải xuống và
sử dụng. Nếu bạn có ý tưởng nào hay, hãy comment bên dưới.
Nếu bạn thấy hay, hãy like, share và subscribe để mình có thêm động
lực làm những video tiếp theo. Đây là skill của anh Ivan và
đã ăn được hơn 40.000 người tài xuống.
Bây giờ mình đã sử dụng con Cloud Code của mình để tóm tắt
xem skill của anh Ivan làm được những gì nha.
Đây là mình đã sử dụng con code code để tóm tắt skill PowerPoint
này của anh. Skill này mục đích là tạo,
kiểm tra và chỉnh sửa các bài thuyết minh PowerPoint focus về bố cục,
template, placeholder và nốt và biểu đồ để kiểm soát chất lượng hình ảnh.
Có 6 quy tắc chính là chọn workflow trước khi sửa,
kiểm kê các text trước khi thay đổi nội dung,
khớp nối nội dung và placeholder thực tế,
bảo tồn ngôn ngữ hình ảnh của text, và chạy QA trên nội dung
và hình ảnh riêng biệt, giữ định dạng để có thể dễ dàng chia sẻ
và review. Và anh chỉ ra một số lỗi thường gặp là placeholder
và biểu đồ mẫu sống sót. nếu rõ ràng,
chỉnh sửa trực tiếp thất bại nếu có vấn đề nằm ở layout,
rồi font thay thế, rồi note and comment media chia sẻ liên kết,
và tỷ lệ khung hình, thế nào cho khớp.
Đó là cơ bản những luật và quy tắc của anh về PowerPoint.
Và để copy, bạn chỉ cần lên trang của anh và copy,
mình đã copy cái skill này của anh về máy của mình.
Chỉ copy đến tận placeholder.
Bạn có thể ignore related skills với feedback.
Sau khi copy về placeholder,
mình đã copy về powerpoint skill của mình đây. Mình chỉ copy tất cả
về. Sau khi đó,
mình sẽ mở con Anti-Gravity của mình lên,
và đầu tiên mình sẽ như là Word
với cả Excel, mình đầu tiên mình sẽ bảo là có thể biến cái
skill PowerPoint của mình để thành skill chính của
AI có thể gọi trong cái thư mục này không.
Đó. Thì mình sẽ bảo AI làm như vậy.
Đây là những điều mà mình muốn AI làm.
Bạn có thể kiểm tra skill Powerpoint MD
thành một skill trên mạng. Trên OAI có thể đọc trên folder này và
mỗi khi mình chỉnh sửa, PowerPoint5 thì
đều dùng skill này và mình sẽ để con Gemini mình chạy OK,
nó đã chạy xong và nó đã update ra một số luật.
Để mình đọc qua xem nó đã update luật nhanh như thế nào nha.
Ở đây thì nó thêm cả PowerPoint để review nữa.
Excel Office như là Doc Excel. và mỗi khi chạy
qua Powerpoint thì nó sẽ phải đọc cái file Powerpoint
này trước, đọc skill của anh Ivan trước từ skillpowerpoint.md
Ok, let đến với demo nào Thì mình sẽ
tạo Powerpoint từ file document này của mình Bây
giờ mình sẽ bảo AI của mình để tạo PowerPoint từ document này.
Đây mình sẽ chia sẻ và mình sẽ bảo tạo PowerPoint từ một PowerPoint
từ chương trình Document Linkage mới, Docs,
chỉ cần những thông tin chính. Và thế để xem xem AI của
mình làm được như thế nào nha.
Xong, con AI của mình đã tạo xong một Powerpoint cho mình tên là
chương trình liên kết tóm tắt Powerpoint.
Để mình mở ra xem Powerpoint như thế nào nha.
Chương trình liên kết tóm tắt. Đây.
Đây là bản Powerpoint mà AI mình đã đã tạo cho mình.
Nó khá là đơn giản và cũng chỉ là liệt kê những thư mục
đơn giản nhất về cái workflow của mình và PowerPoint,
không có một template nào cả.
Mình luôn có POM Setup Skill ở dưới mô tả.
Nếu bạn có ý tưởng nào hay, hãy comment bên dưới.
Hãy like, share và subscribe để mình có thêm động lực làm những video
tiếp theo. Thank you.